Hey brian,
how's it going?
Oh,
hey.
How are you doing?
Suraj pretty good.
Do you mind if I asked you 67 questions?
Sure.
Her.
All right,
let's do this.
So what's life like it in video?
Well,
I think in video is a speed of light company,
so we're always trying to figure out what the boundaries are and push as close
as we can to them.
What's the application of deep learning you're currently the most excited about?
I'm most excited about graphics for deep learning.
Uh,
obviously Nvidia cares a lot about graphics and cares a lot about AI and there's
some opportunities to really change the way we create and render graphics with
deep learning.
You got your phd from Berkeley.
Do you need,
you need a PAC for deep learning?
No,
you don't.
Some of my favorite researchers don't have PhDs solely fine.
Favorite part of the software stack?
Um,
hi,
love compilers.
Compilers are pretty awesome.
You spent two years in Russia and learned Russian.
I did.
Right.
Tell me a phrase in Russian Yamahas new bill.
You're both just show up.
We'd Emojis Dushay Mia who?
Goslin Yusuf Sam
describes Kuda in one sentence.
Cuda is Cindy parallel programming done right?
What's one thing you wish people knew more about?
Kuda um,
I wish that people knew that with Folta our newest gps,
it's a lot more like parallel programming on a CPU and all the threads can work
independently spread.
What do you do to relax?
Uh,
I went to bake.
What comes after gps in terms of AI processing hardware.
GPS are the best processors for AI.
If you could spend an evening with one famous person,
who would it be?
I have to go with President Obama.
You invented a language called copperhead.
Was that as difficult as it sounds?
It was a lot of work.
Um,
it's,
it's interesting.
A lot of the ideas behind comprehend are now pretty common.
And frameworks like torch blue on last thing you made with your hands,
a loaf of raisin bran.
Conrad,
what's the next problem you want to solve?
A,
I'm really focused on reinventing graphics.
They die.
What advice would you give yourself 10 years ago?
I would say more deep learning.
What website do you waste time?
Uh,
I love the beyond three d forums and youtube.
Last person you emailed my boss,
Jonah all.
Then you get an all expenses paid trip to one city.
Where do you go?
I like to go back to,
you can see it in book in the middle of the URL region and Russia.
Would you visit Mars?
Of course.
Who would,
what is one thing you can't live without?
My computer.
Favorite research paper of 2018 and have to say it was the glow paper from open
Ai.
What texts editor do you use?
EMACS.
What open library do you really like?
High torch.
What's one of your favorite movies?
Uh,
arrival.
What is something you do to come up with project ideas?
Do a lot of brainstorming in Google docs and no idea is too stupid to put down.
You worked for Baidu for two years.
How was that experience?
If I do is great.
Uh,
it was very fast paced and lots of wonderful technology is being created there.
so I had a wonderful experience there.
I did kind of run into the limits of what I could do since I was remote working
in America.
And so I'm glad to be working back at Nvidia.
Will China dominate AI in the next decade?
I think they've got a lot of people working really hard and they're doing
amazing things.
What was the first program you ever made?
First Program I ever made was on our old Timex Sinclair 1000 and I was making
little plots
what the music genre you're currently into.
A,
I'm super obsessed with modern choral music.
Arvo pair is like my favorite.
Is there a programming language you really don't like?
Java script
programming,
language of choice for machine learning,
python,
favorite professor and ring.
What is one area of Ai that interests you a lot?
Um,
right now I guess I'd have to say language modeling.
Super interesting.
What is a misconception people have about technology in general that is built
out of breakthroughs one after another?
Actually,
a lot of technology comes step by step.
Name,
one person you really admire.
Um,
one person I really admire.
Uh,
Dave Patterson,
who's that?
Dave Patterson.
The adventure of risk.
What is the most beautiful thing in the world?
A redwood tree.
What do you want to work on the most?
Um,
I'm most excited about unsupervised learning.
What are the people that you've met at technology conferences like,
oh,
they're normal people may be a little bit more focused.
Uh,
generally fun to have technical conversations with.
Describe an ideal culture in one word.
Self-Aware.
Best advice you've ever received.
Um,
be honest with yourself.
You think you need a phd to do deep learning?
No,
I don't.
Well,
the singularity happened.
I don't think it will.
Not In the way that we're worried about.
What is one area of Ai that doesn't get enough love systems.
What is one of the most surprising things you've ever learned from your studies
in deep learning
that deep learning models can actually,
it's very surprising and people take it for granted,
but like why?
Why should that be true?
What is the meaning of life 42?
What was the last thing that frustrated you?
I don't have enough gps for my research.
What's your spirit animal?
A snake.
If you had a time machine,
when would you visit?
Uh,
I think I'd go with 1969
favorite Linux distro who been to what's the best cryptocurrency to invest in?
I don't believe in cryptocurrency investment.
Where would you like to see yourself in the next five years?
I'd really like to see some of the interventions from our lab making a
difference to in video.
Do you think molecular computing will become a reality?
Yes.
And I think we're on the way there already.
If you ran the world,
what is one log you to net?
Um,
I would push for advanced nuclear power to reduce our carbon emissions.
What's a problem that you would love to see solved?
Global warming.
What is the risk that comes from deep learning?
Economic disparity.
Who is one person you looked up to when you were in college?
When I was in college.
Uh,
okay.
I don't know.
It's too hard a question.
What were you like as a kid in grade school?
I was pretty ambitious and pretty extroverted.
I really liked to go up to people and tell them why I was really,
really smart.
I was kind of annoying.
What resource do you use the most to learn about the latest brace?
Twitter.
What's something that excites you about the future of that?
Almost all of the people who have ever worked on AI are working on it right now.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is one learning resource you would use to learn deep learning fast.ai?
Awesome.
Well,
thank you so much for taking the time to answer those questions,
Brian.
Great.
That's fine.
All right.
Have a good one.